Well,
that's another great question.
I actually think of myself primarily as
a political intellectual and so,
um,
I think,
uh,
a lot of what drove me into legal
academia was at,
rather than another kind of academia was
the idea that I wanted to do something
that was politically engaged with the
world.
So my first level is literature as an
English major.
As an undergraduate.
I still teach law and literature
classes.
I do actually think that literature,
it's a lot to tell us about civil
rights,
but at the same time I was very
politically active and many,
many humanists to go to law school,
have their stories so it need not
detained as long.
But my thought was if I actually care
about these causes,
I can probably do more for them than to
write papers on the renaissance about
them.
And so when I went to law school and I
thought,
really,
maybe I should go into practice,
but once I delved into the practical or
the world of practice,
I should say,
uh,
I quickly realized that part of what was
really important to me was the ideas and
intellectual enterprise.
And so I split the difference by
becoming a legal academic who is very
engaged in politics and in activism,
particularly gay rights activism,
but civil rights activism or broadly,
uh,
who nonetheless,
I hope is trying to generate some new
ideas about how this kind of activism
activism.